Brazil home of that one famous statue
that I don't know the name of because
I'm too embarrassed to Google come at me
bro Jesus statue we we tend to think of
Brazil as being synonymous with soccer
beaches and of course the Rio Carnival
the exuberant celebration that has
inspired breathless newsreel reports
since the 1930s down in Rio they're
turning night into day it's the final
day of the big carnival and a mere
couple of million karaokes Brazilians -
you are out on a great whoopi yes those
fan seeking Carioca at having themselves
a great whoopie what an excitable group
of people they are what a fun punch now
I will be the first with me it's the
tone of British news newsreels in the
past he's breathtakingly condescending
although before you get too judgmental
you might want to see an American one
from the same era Brazil itself is
larger than the whole of the United
States and it has millions of acres of
land that no white man has ever seen
oh that basic geography lesson just took
a pretty racist turn the point is none
of us have our hands clean anyway the
reason the reason that I want to talk
about Brazil tonight is that they had a
massive election today the first of two
rounds of voting to elect among other
things a new president and what results
are coming in as we speak it is worth
talking about it for a number of reasons
first a Brazilian politics can be a lot
of fun as we've mentioned before
broadcasters have to provide free
airtime to political parties and some
candidates use that airtime to really
around over the years they've been
ads for a guy dressed as a grasshopper a
dancing chicken a small elderly version
of Robin a surprisingly healthy-looking
asama bin Laden
Captain America a husky spider-man and
my favorite Geraldo Wolverine
now I know what you're thinking if
Hillary adjust on that things would have
been a lot different well maybe maybe
maybe but the point we'll never know
will we
we'll never know this election has been
crazy for reasons that go well beyond
novelty Wolverines and if you're
thinking why should I care about it well
first that's a pretty hostile way to put
it but second Brazil is home to 200
million people it's the fifth largest
country on Earth and they could be on
the brink of massive change but his
Brazilians are pissed off right now one
recent survey found that 95% of them say
their countries headed in the wrong
direction as you will see tonight there
is a very real chance that they're about
to elect a dangerous ideologue with
potentially disastrous consequences so
let us look at why that is the case and
the first thing that you really need to
understand is that Brazil is just
emerging from the worst recession in its
history millions are out of work and in
some regions crime is out of control
last year there were more than 63,000
homicides in Brazil that's more than
Europe and the United States combined
and if you live in Rio
you're probably acutely aware of that
fact turreted percent of the citizen
that lives the real was in a middle of a
crossfire once in the last year 30% were
in the middle of crossfire at that point
Rio's Weather Channel should probably
include crossfire in their forecasts
today's looking partly cloudy with a 30
percent charge about hailstorm of
bullets so maybe bring a light flak
jacket with you and the general
dissatisfaction about crime has been
exacerbated by a gigantic corruption
scandal arising from the investigation
known as Operation car wash and I
realize that that doesn't sound like the
name of a major investigation it sounds
like a Netflix original comedy starring
Kevin James that for some reason you'll
be recommended because you watched one
episode of chef's table I don't know I
don't know what your algorithm is
Netflix but I hate it
now now operation carwash and the
scandal uncovered by it is way too
complicated to get into now suffice to
say that it involves this gas station
these two companies inflated contracts
bribes and kickbacks to government
officials and an elderly gentleman who
flew around the world with bricks of
cash shrink-wrapped
and straps beneath thigh-high socks and
a Spanx like vest which really explains
this year's hottest Halloween costume
sexy carwash co-conspirator and look the
sheer scale of this scandal is
absolutely mind-blowing as the elite
prosecutor will tell you how does
carwash compare to Watergate carwash is
much much bigger bigger than Watergate
much bigger we already have charged more
than two hundred people for hundreds of
crimes the amounts of bribes paid go up
to about two billion dollars billion
dollars and bigger than Watergate
Richard Nixon must be spinning in his
grave right now oh wait a second pull
out a bit no he's escaped again he's
done it again god damn it tricky dick
you're so tricky yes so tricky
operated carwash has rocked Brazilians
faith in their government to its very
core and the people there are
understandably disillusioned I think
Brazil is heading towards complete chaos
that is my impression politicians are
not governing it's a complete mess I'm
going to cast a blank ballot because we
don't know who to vote for anymore we
put ourselves in this situation the
country of the future is the country of
misery the country of misery that's just
not a phrase you expect to come out of
Brazil
it's afraid to expect to be the official
tourism slogan of Great Britain come to
read me we promise there will be no
great whoopee so whose job will it be to
try and turn things around in Brazil
well the most popular politician in
Brazil by far is this guy former
President Luiz inácio Lula da Silva he's
beloved for presiding over a period of
prosperity there in which social
programs were expanded and millions were
lifted out of poverty he was actually
running to retake his office and was
projected to win easily there was just
one
issue one of brazil's most influential
political figures is now in police
custody former Brazilian President Luiz
Lula da Silva turned himself in on
Saturday to serve a 12 year sentence for
corruption yep Lula was caught up in
operation car wash - and he claims that
the charges against him were politically
motivated and many supporters believe
him in fact he's still so popular the
polls showed he would have won the
election if he'd been allowed to run
from prison which kind of makes sense
because electing a president who is
already in prison for corruption does
save you this seemingly inevitable
hassle of having to put your president
in prison for corruption it's a time
saver if nothing else
now since Lula is out his party is
running Fernando Haddad in his place
he's the former mayor of Sao Paulo and
he's generally little known him in the
rest of Brazil and instead of trying to
build up a brand of his own daddys
desperately trying to play up his
similarity to Lula in a series of
campaign ads it's subtle but just see if
you can catch it that is just an insult
to people's intelligence you can't just
spin a sign and make people forget which
guy is which I can't make you mix up
Gary Busey and Lucille Ball by spinning
a sign and going goosey loosey goosey
loosey goosey loosey goosey loosey
goosey loosey why because you will still
know which one is America's Sweetheart
and which was married to Desi Arnaz now
the fact is the fact is a dad has his
work cut out for him here because not
only is he not Lula their party the
Workers Party or PT has been heavily
tainted by recent scandals and many
Brazilians are eager for a radical
change and that brings us to the man
currently leading in the polls
Jaya volson ro and the nicest thing that
you can say for him is he has not been
implicated in a corruption investigation
yet unfortunately that's literally the
only nice thing that I can possibly find
to say about him because he is a
terrible human being for a start he's a
big fan of doing finger guns
seriously he does this all the
time there is even video of him teaching
a little girl how to do them for some
reason
and look liking finger guns as far as
I'm concerned is an immediate character
flaw it puts him in the August company
of Michael Scott's children pretending
to be Cowboys and that co-worker who
says things like working hard or hardly
working that everybody hates
unfortunately it only gets worse from
there a member of the Brazilian Congress
since 1991 and known for his sometimes
racist misogynistic homophobic and even
undemocratic views bolson arrow has
passed himself as a political outsider
offensive for most it is his outspoken
nature that has many saying he's
Brazil's version of Donald Trump it's
true he's become known there as the
Brazilian Trump which is both
politically worrisome and also the
grossest style to order and a pubic hair
salon I'll take the up Brazilian Trump
please it's what you rip everything off
the front area but you come some ass
hair around to give the illusion of hair
that's what it is I'm not showing you
that you're imagining it that's in your
head don't be angry with me be angry
with yourself
now unfortunately boss Nara has fired up
many young people in Brazil particularly
from the middle and upper classes there
are some incredible videos online of him
turning up to airports only to be mobbed
by a crowd lifting him onto their
shoulders and chanting for him it is
some intense support and it's worrying
that young people are so excited by him
because he is an extreme hard right
conservative he wants to withdraw Brazil
from the Paris agreement on climate
change and weaken environmental
regulations
he's called refugees arriving in Brazil
the scum of the world and as for crime
he wants to make it easier for
Brazilians to buy guns presumably so
they can fight it themselves but he also
favors some psychotically strong law
enforcement saying a policeman who
doesn't kill isn't a policeman which
incredibly still isn't even in the top
10 most alarming statements that he's
made and some way that he'd actually go
much further
Boston aura has said in the past I am in
favor of a dictatorship which is
particularly worried
as he's a former military captain in a
country that until 1985 was ruled by a
brutal military dictatorship and while
that regime engaged in torture and
extrajudicial killings balsa Morrow has
said that that mistake was that they
simply didn't go far enough I'm in favor
of torture you know that and the people
are too through the vote you won't
change anything in this country nothing
absolutely nothing it's only going to
change unfortunately when we get to a
civil war doing the job that the
military regime didn't do killing 30,000
Wow
he's pretty jarring to hear someone
claim that a military dictatorship
didn't kill enough people he's like
saying Hugh Hefner didn't enough in
the last days of his life really really
because I'm pretty sure the amount he
did it was already a human rights abuse
and regarding Boston arrows famous
homophobia and misogyny it really has to
be seen to be believed
first take a look at how he won't spoke
to a female member of Congress I would
never rape you because you're not worth
it I hope not because I'd slap you in
the face do it I'll slap you back do it
I'll slap you back do it I'll slap you
back what's this are you pushing me do
it I'll slap you back holy he
starts he starts there with I'd never
rape you because you're not worth it and
then somehow manages to top that
terrible statement
that's like saying sorry kids Christmas
is canceled this year why because I've
murdered Santa Claus and both stars
homophobia if any if anything is
actually even worse because in interview
after interview he has said some more
horrifying things he cackles they throw
6 fresco they want to reach our children
in order to turn the children into gay
adults to satisfy their sexuality in the
future if your child starts to become
like that a little gay you take a whip
and you change their behavior people say
it's discrimination but you who's
watching from home would you hire a gay
driver to take your children to school
of course not
that's just appalling and it's frankly
taking all the restraint that I have
right now not to release a charmingly
Illustrated children's book called
Marlon bando punches that guy right
square in the face
which is already very comfortably is
watch what happened when Ellen Page went
to challenge Bolton ro on some of his
views I'm gay so do you think that I
should have been beaten as a child
should not be gay now I'm not going to
look at you and say I think you're gay
that doesn't matter to me you're very
nice if I were a cadet in the Military
Academy and saw you on the street I
would whistle at you all right you're
very pretty
what are you doing he just told her I
wouldn't beat you I would cat call you
and seemed to genuinely think that was a
compliment
and look how confused that made Ellen
Page do you know how hard it is to
confuse Ellen Page she was in Inception
that should be simply as if Polaris Camp
Patton was not already dramatic enough
you may have heard he was actually
stabbed a few weeks ago during a
campaign rally which is absolutely
horrific although although he says that
he's making a full recovery and you can
tell that he is feeling better because
when he was in hospital he pulled out
what else the finger guns
now Bob's our support has actually
increased since that attack even Geraldo
Wolverine endorsed him in this bizarre
video
ah I hate what he's doing I love the way
he's doing it yeah look why is Wolverine
endorsing Boston ro I don't know why
does he seem to be driving a Ford Focus
that quest there's a lot of questions of
that video raises and I just don't have
the answers to any of them well look
there may be some small reason for hope
here a huge movement has emerged in the
last couple of weeks called Ln yow or
not him there have been massive marches
against Boston ro all over Brazil and as
you have seen tonight voting for not him
is a truly excellent idea now today's
election was supposed to just determine
who went into a two-person runoff on
October 28th but if any candidate got
fifty percent or above there would be no
second round they would just be Brazil's
president and as of right now the vote
tally shows Bolton ro and around 48
percent with over three-quarters of the
votes counted so while he will probably
go to a runoff with her dad there is
still a chance that he's going to win
outright tonight and when you think
about it why wouldn't that happen
between taping this show and airtime
boston ro could have won Ruth Bader
Ginsburg could have been eaten by a bear
and every kitten spores could have been
replaced by octopus tentacles
oh that's very possible because it seems
that that's what life is now but
if bolton ro has not won if there is
going to be a runoff in three weeks then
it still it isn't too late that's the
thing and Brazil please look I realize
that you are disgusted with your
politics in the moment and you're not
inspired by any of the alternatives but
anything is better than Boston ro diet
Lula is better
spider-man is better Gary Busey is
better that is Gary Busey I'm pretty
sure that's him the point is Boston ro
does not reflect the best of who you are
Brazil and with any luck you still have
a chance to vote la now and not let this
man finger bang your democracy
you